e
en la actualidad hay mucha presión por
la tecnología especialmente en idaho y
me sentía muy nerviosa que se tratara de
sacar a la maestra del camino y
sustituirla por las computadoras
ahora soy inútil soy una niñera una
facilitadora y ya no soy una maestra
antes no me gustaban las matemáticas
porque eran muy difíciles antes no me
gustaban nada las matemáticas antes me
arrastraban para ir a la escuela era
aburrido no quería hacer ejercicios todo
el día pero después de khan me despierto
y bueno todavía me siento así en las
otras clases pero me gusta cuando voy a
tener matemáticas ha sido impactante
pensé que me distanciaría de los chicos
pensé que los chicos se sentaría en
frente a sus computadoras que no habría
mucha interacción y me preocupaba que
provocará este distanciamiento y ha
resultado lo opuesto completamente
ahora con khan academy puedo ver los
vídeos las vistas y especialmente las de
la señorita heart es nuestra maestra
ahora enseño mejor que nunca en mis 13
años como maestra tengo mucho más tiempo
personal con los
les enseño lo que necesitan cuando lo
necesitan en realidad importa no porque
al final se reduce a que estarás en
buena forma en lugar de esperarte a ver
si está correcto o no en lugar de hacer
20 o 30 problemas y sacarlos todos mal
creen que lo están haciendo bien y les
da gusto pero luego llegan a clase y se
dan cuenta que están mal pero no sabían
ahora con khan cuando resuelven un
problema descubren de inmediato si están
bien o mal si lo tuvieron mal pueden ir
paso a paso en la resolución y ver
exactamente dónde se equivocaron para
que la próxima vez lo hagan mejor y no
tengo que sentarme con ellos a hacer eso
yo puedo estar enseñando continuar con
mi lección y ese chico puede resolver su
problema por sí mismo si no puede viene
conmigo hay tantos recursos entre sus
compañeros y las piezas de aprendizaje
en khan academy que puede aprender por
sí mismo yo estoy ahí para apoyarlos
cuando eso no funciona o para enseñarles
antes
antes no era muy buena y ahora les estoy
enseñando a otras personas cómo hacerlo
si tú sabes algo y no sabes otra cosa y
tal vez tus compañeros lo saben es como
si fueras el profe y el alumno al mismo
tiempo es solo
mejor si no me creen los invito a que
vengan y vean la fuerza que existe en la
esta clase que vean las conexiones
sociales los lazos cuanto están
aprendiendo cada día y lo grandiosos que
se sienten estos chicos todos los días
ah